i read something very interesting that
ftx as a you know 30 billion company
only has um
like 200 employees or something like
that and i believe you you know for the
first year the product was built by just
two engineers and even now you only have
sub 20 sub 30 engineers
a is that true
and b
what the hell is going on like do you is
ftx he's like
he's like i can only think of one of two
things either ftx is simply like you
have a unique set of problems so you
could do you can operate your business
differently or the rest of us are doing
this completely wrong which is it
and um and he goes the latter
[Music]
what up birthday boy
thank you what's good how's it going
uh it's going okay i um you know
a little bit i was gonna sing to you
you facetimed me
i facetimed you earlier
oh i'm sorry i didn't even get the
notification i was uh i had to
personalize
but uh you did miss out on what would
have been a good serenade actually can i
tell you a funny story about that wait
was your kids there
no it was just me and ben um
oh man what a bummer i'd rather see your
kids though i've got baby fever
oh nice yeah well actually my son was
there but you know before the age of
like two they're kind of just like an
inanimate of an object that you just
carry around
i was working out and when i work out i
put my phone on like focus mode or
whatever so i'm sorry but thank you
swole mode so uh
how old are you now
33 okay you're getting up there too all
right i like it uh so you're i think a
year younger than me we um
i was at a birthday party uh like two
weekends ago
i had to leave the house it was crazy
and we get there and this guy did this
thing that i saw and i was like oh what
an amazing
little life hack
he basically had so it's like some kid's
birthday party they sing happy birthday
it's time to blow out the candles and
cut the cake and the guy grabs the mic
and he's like hold on hold on
we got a special birthday song for you
and this guy apparently because my wife
knows him she's like oh my god he's
doing it he always does this and it's
like he has his own version of happy
birthday that he sings
but it's not like a singing thing it's
more like
um like he's indian so it's kind of like
an indie vibe to it but let's just
pretend it's sort of like when i say
happy you say birthday happy and
everyone was like birthday happy
birthday he's like he's like
i always love all those
of course it's like you know there's
something in my body that just i can't
help but become like you know the the
the follow the leader during that moment
and he'll be like you know who's the
birthday boy sam sam sam right it's like
it'll make you feel good and then um
and i was like what a life hack to just
be the life of the party is to
simply have a cool version of happy
birthday that you can do
uh that's amazing that's like having a
joke that just always kills so listen to
this i've got this friend named and
jonathan we'll get we'll get to the
sameer thing in a second but i have this
friend named nick ray uh sean do you
know who nick ray is
i know of him i don't know i don't think
i've ever met him but i've seen his like
his like website and like you've told me
about him and uh he looks like he's like
an entrepreneur but he kind of looks a
little bit slick i don't know who he is
so i i call him grown-up dennis the
menace because he looks like a 40 year
old dennis the menace like if you think
of like what dennis diminished would
look like when he's 40 that's like a
dick he had a company called uh he had
one business that was like it worked it
was the aviation industry sold it then
he started this thing called museum hack
which was like you pay like 25 or
something like that um and you get a
group museum tour like a private museum
tour whatever he sold it and then he
loves hosting parties so much
that i believe he used scribed like you
did
and he wrote a book on how to host the
perfect two-hour evening party
and this guy yes i'll i'll try to find
the the title have you read it
it just came out like two days ago and
he just sent me a copy it's called the
here i'll find it but it uh it's like uh
it's like how to host the perfect
cocktail party and this guy whenever he
hosts parties he brings name tags to all
every time you're with him he has a name
tag a kite a frisbee and a blanket i'm
telling you this guy's like a 12 year
old that's like growing up dennis the
menace
because he's just like he's like these
are the best things
to bring to like a park party and uh
they just it just works and so he brings
this to like all of his parties and it's
hilarious i bring the rule book to the
game red rover and it's a great
icebreaker to play the game red rover
it's been working since preschool
and he brings like a harmonica and when
he goes he'll like play the harmonica
and he goes all right everyone come to
the circle and he like does these
icebreakers it's hilarious so the book
is called uh the two hour cocktail party
and it's just a book on hosting a
two-hour cocktail party he's been
working on it for like two years so give
him a shout out but i actually wasn't
i'm only bringing this up because we
were talking about hosting the perfect
party and everything it's hilarious and
it's like might actually become like a
brand around host it's like you know
like maria condo made like putting your
clothes away into like a martha
stewart's dies business that's what this
guy might be doing like a cocktail party
oh wow okay so i have three instant
reactions to this
number one
what a great idea
what a great idea because
when you first said it i laughed which
to me already means this is kind of
remarkable as a product meaning
you you had to remark on it it was worth
telling so that's already like a good
thing second thing is it's actually a
real problem like nobody teaches you how
to do things in life that are life stuff
and so if you can hone in on a piece of
life stuff like you know the classic
example is like you know
the book the game which is like you know
about how to like pick up women like how
do you approach a stranger that you're
interested in and like
you know can you get a date and like we
all laugh and say oh man that's so uh
you know people will sort of point at it
be like you know the sort of a loser
thing right in reality best-selling book
it was one of the best books i've ever
read um and like really helpful a lot of
people who literally don't know how to
navigate this social situation that they
get put in yeah i dude i think it's
awesome
yeah so by the way look at the link i
sent you i sent the link in riverside
and i didn't realize this but look at
the reviews the
reviews are all of our friends so it's
nick huber it's kat from best self it's
ben the guy who uh i think he started uh
what's that
group on deck sarah and then david your
wife
is she on there
she might be here
yeah it could be her and then david
perell's on there they're all like the
isn't that hilarious they're all like
they're reviewers or whatever uh i don't
know yeah i agree it's a pretty pretty
funny niche to own
so my first thought is
it's actually what a great idea helping
people know how to host a party just
like fun in a box it's like look you
don't have to be creative and you don't
have to have experience doing this like
i will help you know the like three or
four things that will make you look
awesome when you do this i think that's
kind of great
second reaction
what a terrible idea why is this a book
why isn't this a twitter thread like if
there's ever a thing which is like this
book could have been an email um like
this book could have been an email i
guarantee it
so that's my second reaction to this
it's just like love the idea of creating
a brand and content on this topic
the book wow overkill like it's a book
takes more than two hours to read uh
like the book shouldn't be longer than
the full party would be in this case i i
kind of agree with you but i think you
have to forget that most people don't
have charisma
and although i think i definitely have
like a little social anxiety i think you
do too like i don't like leaving my
house that often i don't want to like
talk to like strangers that often but
like i could like i can turn it on and
be like all right fine i'm in that mode
uh i think most people like all of our
like nerdy ass friends i just don't
think they just like stand around like
what do i do with my hands like they
don't know like where to hold their
hands they don't know anything
that's amazing
actually dude i i still remember so i've
been to a bunch of like startup events i
was in this accelerator called the mass
challenge back in the day it's like a
boston based like startup accelerator i
don't even know how i ended up there and
i've heard i would say at this point in
my life i've heard at least 500
in person
like talks to entrepreneurs okay 500.
if you know what's the most memorable
one it was this guy this old school guy
who came he was probably in his late 60s
and he's like
he did two things
the first one was he goes
all right um
you guys are all entrepreneurs somebody
stand up and pitch me your business tell
me what your business does and somebody
would stand up they'd be like hey we uh
i'll go i'll go right it's like a
bravery contest i'll go a thousand hands
go up because he's entrepreneurs you got
it you got to be the one who's like
courageous so every raise your hand pick
the first guy um sam i hope you know i'm
ceo of the hustle we're a media company
for millennials who love to learn about
business
no you're not actually i forgot the very
first thing the best part of the whole
thing is he started the talk from the
back of the room
and he was like he's like
and everybody's looking at the stage all
the chairs face one way right and he's
like i'm back here entrepreneurship you
gotta adjust
that was the first time it's like you
know
dodgeball whatever you want to
so this guy was like that guy and he's
like i'm in the back of the room what
are you gonna do and he's like uh he's
like all of a sudden you gotta adjust
turn your seat around are you stuck to
the ways that the society works are you
just gonna do what makes sense and so
that's how he started then he goes and
he's like picture business and if if you
just said like i'm sean um
you know we're the milk road we uh you
know we we're a uh a web3 focused uh
newsletter that does no he would just
cut you off but he wouldn't tell you
what you're doing wrong and his process
of elimination everyone is trying one
thing and then finally some guy said it
right he goes we're smart shade
um
you know when you're in a room and it's
too bright through the window we help
you
make sure that you have a shade on there
that doesn't make your room look ugly
and the guy was like yes
that's exactly right you explain the
situation and you use the key word help
your business exists to help someone do
something help someone get some outcome
some benefit he's like all of you guys
think you're entrepreneurs and you
couldn't tell me who you're helping do
what and then we're all like oh we're
like reeling and then he transitioned
into he goes
put up a diagram of a of a meeting room
of a bunch of six chair table or like an
eight chair table it goes
biggest meeting of your life where do
you sit
hey smart trade guy where do you sit
[Laughter]
the chairs had numbers on them and
you're like three
and he's like no
he's like you sit in chair two it's the
corner of the table so you're not the
head of the table but you're the corner
of the table you have like you know sort
of like 80 of the visibility as the head
of the table but you now have both
angles you're kind of at the wide angle
where people can see you and talk to you
and then he showed another diagram of
like another a round table where do you
sit at a round table if this is the door
where do you go sit uh then he's like
you have five minutes before the uh your
meeting is about to start in 10 minutes
not everybody's there you have 10
minutes to talk to the number two person
what do you say and he was like giving
these like real world social and
businesses
around
i don't remember that was like you know
uh you you go to the other you basically
go like i don't know it's like you don't
have your back to the door you kind of
have a side-facing uh thing to the door
you don't want to be directly facing the
door because then you're like a little
child sitting in your seat waiting for
the teacher to come back like you know
you do that and like in your small talk
thing he's like do you talk about the
weather in sports no
uh he's like you've done already eight
hours of research on this person you
already know abcde and you were going to
bring up this topic and so this guy was
like so opinionated so crazy but i
remember it because he was answering
things that i felt like nobody had
instructed me how to do and it was the
where do i what do i do with my hands
while i talk problem which is like i
definitely run into these situations and
i've received zero guidance in my life
on what i'm supposed to do and if you
have like the solution in a box i'll
take it
that's interesting well nick's going to
freaking love that because uh
you know like cocktails parties is such
a niche thing but
he'll probably do well he's pretty
successful um
so we want to talk about colin sameer
jonathan so colin sameer that episode
went live
on youtube
people probably noticed
john so we have it's shawn and me and
ben typically and jonathan most of the
time is actually on air i actually don't
know jonathan why you're on air like why
you're here but i know what you do as a
job you grow the podcast but i don't
know like why you actually need to be
sitting here why why do you stay here
um one because this is fun and two
this is the only time i can get like
face time with y'all to
talk about these types of things so it's
like my only time i can actually carve
out time on yale's calendar
our calendar
we are the issue
he slacks us he asks us to do stuff and
we just never respond like yeah it makes
perfect sense it's like you know oh why
did you open the sushi restaurant
because like because i knew you loved
sushi and i just needed to get your
approval on these three things like damn
we're that much of an [__] sorry
sorry jonathan i apologize that we are
not very responsive in general
and so he came on
and you said you said hey talk about the
colin smear thing because a it was
interesting and what was the b
um i think there's just like some good
takeaways that we should probably
implement
into our youtube channel
youtube and the podcast as well um but
first of all i've hosted a nick grey
party and it was awesome and like like
you just described sean like there's so
much nuance to
you know like hosting a good meeting and
like where you sit and how the
experience is for everyone else and so
you kind of do need a book to like piece
all that together chapter one here's the
pre you know party stuff and all that
but
yeah email templates and all that stuff
are kind of necessary and all that wait
wait wait wait wait wait you said you
hosted a nick great party what does that
mean you you did his method or you
attended a party dude he's like famous
he he did like a beta launch for his
book and so a few people myself included
hosted one of like the beta parties
wow
wow wow this is you're blowing my mind
right now hold on
wow holy [__] dude he's like famous in
austin it's hilarious which by the way
we gotta give him a proper shout out so
it's nick gray g-r-a-y i believe his
website is nickray.net so if you want to
go and learn whatever go ahead
so you were like a pilot for this thing
first of all how much of a friggin early
adopter are you that you like knew about
a book that's not even written yet and
you were like i'll be one of your test
cases to test your your party thing okay
wait give us the rundown give me like
one or two of the golden nuggets that
like you wouldn't otherwise have done at
a party that nick kind of like helped
you try out
yeah well so nick everyone just kind of
knows nick and austin if if you're kind
of running in the same circles and so i
went to another guy who hosted a nick
gray party and i was like this is
awesome and so and i knew the guy so i
was like let's co-host the next one and
we had it at my house i got like a
backyard and everything um and so the
takeaways were i went i bought a house
uh i got ready for this
uh yeah we got pizza and it was just it
reminded me of kind of like a prom party
just to begin with but the pieces that
were uh
kind of crucial are
the one like the icebreakers so like you
start the night with like you know
everyone's getting their drinks and
getting comfortable and stuff like that
and then you blow the harmonica or
whatever you're like you play you strap
the banjo or whatever it is you strum
the banjo
and you get everyone's attention be like
hey we're doing icebreakers say your
name and then like the fun fact would be
like what was the first thing you did
for money and so it kind of gets people
like you know to get a little bit deeper
and then that can lead into the next
conversation and so on and so forth so
there's like two or three of those
throughout the night and then you know
it's just like the email before the
email after and like how you
nurture those people i guess and like
actually
you know connect them and all the little
things like that but
i feel like there's like a bunch of
little hacks like emailing is part of
this template i didn't even
think about an email as part of the
experience dude he's got a whole [__]
about it and the funny thing about nick
is he's like he's very flamboyant like
he's like gregarious but he's like loud
and a lot of people think that he's gay
and he gets more girls than anyone i've
ever met and it's mostly because of this
party this party stuff he like he like
dates so many like well i i won't say
that i'll say girls love him
women love this guy and uh
partially because
it's called straight up gay
[Laughter]
he kills it this guy is very interesting
that's another huge thing about this is
like when you become the connector when
you're hosting these parties like once a
month or once a quarter like that's
really valuable when you're able to like
kind of be that person they're like oh
i'm gonna reach out to jonathan because
he knows x y and z or whatever so
that's like kind of what you did in san
francisco i feel like with the hustle
meetups right yeah it is a hack it
totally works
and sean did the same thing because we
hosted like all of our events at his
house like at his office so he was like
my proxy was like the man
dude so i know we probably have other
things to talk about but i'm so mind
blown by this and i just have so much
more that i need to know okay so
uh give me okay so give me something
that is
you wouldn't um expect it right like
let's say
uh maybe like i don't know okay like
email kind of counts the harmonic is a
great example of this like have a little
instrument that will help get people's
attention and like you know just kind of
like lightens the mood a little bit by
just hearing it's like you know great
sound give me another one
let me give one jonathan he hosted a
party one time called a petting zoo
party and he hired like a mobile petting
zoo for like 400
or i don't even know what it was but it
wasn't like a big deal and it like was
the most fun at a party i just sat
around and petted like rabbits and like
guinea pigs
and it was awesome so he like does
themes like then he'll have a dinosaur
theme where you wear like dinosaur
themed clothing which i don't know what
that means but what else jonathan what
else does he do
again i've only been to like one or two
but it's
if it's not that like you really don't
need to
put a theme around it if you're just
doing something super simple like i did
but like if you want to make it a little
more memorable like
yeah i feel like he's done like uh he
just did a paddle board thing where like
everyone went out to like austin and
were on their paddle boards and like did
a whole thing there and he had a thing
where he gave numbers
he gave a whiteboard to three different
people and he said we're having a diving
contest so the best the person who has
the best cannonball off of their
paddleboard and he he goes the
contestants are and he had already
planned he goes there this person this
person and this person you guys get up
front and do your cannonball and we're
all gonna and these three judges are
gonna give you a review the second or
third thing that he does is he has a
very specific end time to the party so
he goes come on over the party's gonna
end at eight o'clock at eight o'clock he
goes all right everyone thank you for
coming the party's over you don't gotta
get you don't gotta go home but you
gotta get out of here and he's like
parties need an end otherwise they drag
on for too long people don't wanna go
anymore and so he always has an ending
to his parties which is actually pretty
great because i go because i'm like i
don't got to sneak out like it's going
to end at a very particular time
so two hour cocked up on it dude we uh
okay i don't know if we're oprah but i
feel like we just sold the [__] out of
this book like uh you know this this guy
he's gonna get a lot of sales from this
uh from this this plug because this was
incredible but honestly i'm genuinely
interested in this topic uh you know i
had heard something once like um charity
water is kind of known for their events
and they raise a ton of money for
charity and like most charity events are
kind of the same old stale like
dinner gala you sort of go it's sort of
a drag in charity waters events you feel
like you're you know
you feel like you're at some like
hollywood party basically and it's not
because they spend more money it's like
they're just more creative with like the
way that they they like create memorable
things and so and every year they top
themselves which is like this impossible
standard it's like
last year the super bowl halftime show
was this this year's gotta be even
bigger that's how they treat their
annual events and they raise like i
don't know 75 million dollars in a night
doing that and that funds clean water
for a lot of people and i remember
asking scott i go
well so what's like how do you think
about these events like how do you
everybody always graves about these i've
never been to one what is the secret
sauce like how do you guys think about
this and he goes oh that's my wife
victoria that's her her thing he goes
she has this phrase which is
um it's about the moments in between the
moments
like it's the moments between the
moments that matter and so it's like
everybody thinks of when they planned
their event okay for dinner we're gonna
do this and then for the dancing we're
gonna do this but they don't think about
the like
20-minute period right before dinner
when it's like getting set up or served
and like the the five-minute walk
between this place to this place or
whatever and if you do something there
people feel like
wow i'm having a like a 10 out of 10
experience because they thought of
everything like they thought of like i
know for charity water it was like
they really thought about like the walk
between um
like where the cocktail hour was and the
dinner and they were like okay yeah you
could just like traverse through this
like you know hallway
but like what can we do in the hallway
that will like send the message and they
basically created like i don't know like
a visual light show of like i don't know
a woman in africa a real woman she
starts when you start and she's carrying
these like 60 pound gallons of water and
there's one on the you see her carrying
it and then 15 steps in there's one
sitting on the ground that you could
pick up and you could try carrying and
by the end of it you've had like it's
like dang that was heavy and that was
hard and i only walked
54 steps
she does that for three hours a day just
to get clean water for her family and
you're like are you likely to donate by
the end of that yeah right it's like but
they just used the hallway as this by
the way i made up this exact example
because i didn't go to the event but
like that was a really good example
that was great
yeah i had to put the disclaimer because
i was like damn i just made up a really
vivid ass lie about what they did at
their event and like scott's big on
integrity so let me be clear that's not
exactly what happened that's what i kind
of remember from him telling me while we
were drunk six years ago and he was
telling me like what he did um so so
yeah but if the moments between the
moments is just a good uh like
phrase to remember when you're gonna
host an event i might write my own book
[__] you nick ray
[Laughter]
all right let's talk about colin and
samir so these
these guys came on they're like these
youtube i don't exactly know how you
describe them but they're popular on
youtube and uh
people seem to like it in the comments
you know my takeaway was sean do you
think being a youtuber is a good life or
not i can't decide actually
i think it's a good life the way they
did it so that the daily vlogger style
i think is a is a tough one and i think
the uh like gaming streamer who's gonna
sit in their chair and play video games
for seven hours a day every day
is not a good no not a bad nor is the mr
beast like i have to up my pranks or my
stunts
like i gotta come up with a new miracle
every month or i lose relevance that to
me is like stressful and to be fair
that's like 75 percent of youtube
success is like daily vlogging
stunts and pranks or like gaming so you
know if you're not that good for you
colin and samir for example not in that
they're an interview show
that's like paced out well they do you
know like whatever one or two a week or
something like that it's not as
treadmilly as other content things what
i'm learning about through them what we
need to do and what more people should
do that woman rebecca uh i keep calling
her like that woman rebecca texted us
and she was like our friend rebecca
our friend rebecca sorry rebecca uh she
uh told us that
this guy she worked with i won't say the
name went from zero to eight was it
eight million subscribers in eight
months or was it like three million and
eight i forget the number but i think it
was eight million
in how many months 12 months like a year
a year yeah
and all from shorts
is that crazy
all from
freaking youtube shorts i never watch
youtube shorts
yeah i i i do i actually watch youtube
choices but the thing is
once i've worked inside a tech company i
was like oh
i get it
like
i'm youtube the biggest threat to my
company is tick tock every day like you
know somebody there's like every every
quarterly off site we're hearing about
the latest tick tock numbers wow their
growth is crazy wow they're blowing us
away wow the stars are going there you
know like
tic tac is your like kind of like main
priority if you're one of these big
social media companies right now
um beyond like you know your core
business like if you're gonna think
about growth you're gonna think about
tick tock
and so you release a competitive product
shorts and you announce it to the world
and you put your best people on it and
like you can't let that feature fail
right away
and so you like you gotta pump the
engagement how do you do that you're
like
all right you know engagement was a 10
out of you know 10 out of 100 okay
uh if we put it at the top of every time
you open the app it jumps to a 40. okay
now we're also going to add it every
three scrolls we're gonna add another
little shorts banner oh also we're gonna
like you know
make it one of our we're gonna change
our recommendation engine to just
recommend a short after a long video and
so you you're gonna try to game the
system to give yourself the best shot at
that feature becoming successful and so
at least in the short term
if you're a creator you say oh their
priority is pushing like you know oh
instagram's priority was pushing stories
and then reels then i'm gonna make great
reels and stories because that's what
they're pushing right now that's what
the algorithm wants to they're gonna
they're gonna favor that in the ui and
the algorithm and so um i'm gonna get
faster growth because i'm sort of like
piggybacking off of their priorities
and i think that's actually a really
good strategy for like if you and i or
uh my first million wanted to get
popular on youtube is just like exploit
the ego of the social media platform
like it totally works just just give
them exactly what they want and not
always but sometimes they'll give you
exactly what you want which is you know
more followers
but are we going to do it
maybe it's clearly a good idea
that we may or may not execute on just
hilarious thing that i saw so uh
there was like some page that's like uh
you know like there's like meme pages on
instagram that get like a bunch of
followers so it's like i had like friday
beers i think this is what it was this
is like friday's
i follow so many of them
yeah they're great they're very humorous
they could post great memes whatever so
they did a collab with something called
like
it was the word entrepreneur but it was
spelled like super whack because like
you know the word entrepreneur is like
kind of a whack word in general so it's
like android and trainee poor and like
that was like the name of the account or
something like that and i went i clicked
on it and the bio cracked me up so hard
it was like cultivating that
trillionaire mindset that
multi-trillionaire mindset and then the
next line was uh mindset is
hashtag grindset
[Laughter]
i have decided that on this podcast our
new intro is gonna be about cultivating
that multi-trillionaire mindset hashtag
grindset and i'm gonna start every
single podcast by saying that and
somebody who doesn't know what i'm
talking about they're gonna be so turned
off but the people who i listen to this
podcast are gonna know
that that is the funniest thing ever
because it is
that's amazing what we're saying
jonathan
um
i i love that
they always also say
they always also say uh read that again
like they'll do the post and then all
the copy and then it's like read that
again
yeah all right guys that's the show
listen to that again go back
you know what you got to do now rewind
for the two time double time get double
get triple trillion our mindset hashtag
great set go back and listen again
what was that phrase the latest post
says
read that again
their latest post says you keep your
money in the bank i keep my fish in the
tank think about it
like you know we named this my first
million and the reason we get flack for
that and the reason we give ourselves
grief for that is because my first
million is in the middle it's like
neither um it's not like trying to be
humble and like um
you know thoughtful about life it's like
no you want to make a million dollars
but it's only a million when you say
we're you know we're all about that
trillionaire lifestyle you you all of a
sudden you it's like hey we are not
trying to be that guy who's trying to
sell you a dream of making a billion
dollars and so i think i realized the
mistake in the name the name should not
have been million uh the whole brand
should have been my first trillion
mindset
it should have been my first trillion
we're a community we're a community of
future multi-trillionaires uh who gather
around
you know
to trade stories
our software is the worst have you heard
of hubspot see most crms are a cobble
together mess but hubspot is easy to
adopt and actually looks gorgeous i
think i love our new crm our software is
the best hubspot grow better
where do you want to go from here did
you have anything on did you have do you
have topics i've got one or two do you
have any
i have a couple uh what do you have i
have a couple i have a couple good ones
okay so what do you want to do you want
to do okay i'll give you three options
a really interesting uh thing i heard
that i i want to get your opinion on
like like a thing about how
a company we a big famous company runs
their company i thought was kind of mind
blowing
number two is an idea that i don't
really even understand as i don't know
what the hell they're doing but maybe
it's cool
and then um
the third is uh you know random business
idea which which one would you like to
go through number one
number one okay so the interesting okay
so
we uh so the milk road our main sponsor
right now is ftx and i don't know if you
like do you know what ftx is dude in my
on my topics i have a thing about how
they run their company and how it's
weird go ahead yeah okay so that's
probably the same thing
is it about how many employees they have
and how many engineers yes
look at the dock i have the exact same
topic go ahead
okay so
so it recently so we we were like as
part of the sponsorship it's like okay
we tell people you know hey ftx is a
great trading platform blah blah blah
and in addition we were like hey we want
to do a deep dive on you guys and i was
like but here's the thing you don't get
to tell us what to write about i'm gonna
like i'm gonna talk to your head of
strategy i'll talk to whoever and um
whatever's the most interesting thing to
me that's what we're gonna do the deep
dive on and so i ended up doing it on
um like the the like kind of like the
seven like growth hacky strategies that
they used to grow because they went from
zero to a 30 billion dollar company in
like three years and so i thought that
was kind of amazing i wrote the whole
thing obviously and then i discovered i
discovered something even more amazing
which is that they built the whole they
built like for the first year or
something they had two engineers and
even now to this day they have like i
think 25 to 30
uh software engineers
and they're amazing i think and i think
they only have 250 people
yeah exactly and so he did this um he
went uh this the guy sam baker freed he
did this talk at the sewn conference and
so sone i don't know if people know it's
spelled s-o-h-n it's like this big kind
of like economic uh annual conference or
whatever and what happens is the big
show like
sam sam bakeman freed is the 29 year old
like 20 or 30 billion dollar fountain
roll he was before the crash but like
decca billionaire guy
uh and he started this coinbase
competitor which is called ftx after he
got rich in bitcoin
yeah it's a platform for people to trade
uh crypto and now stocks and other
things but
basically he he talks there and if
you've ever watched these i don't have
you ever watched other sewn conference
talks they're very interesting to go go
back and look because
you get the it's the bit it's like a ted
talk for it's ted but just for like um
invest investors uh just for like
finance and wall street people so like
bill ackman will go on there and you can
look at his old videos by the way if you
go watch these so here's what here's my
journey i'm like bill like my man this
guy's really smart and our buddy andrew
wilkinson loves bill ackman says he's
the best and um and i go back and i'll
go look for old youtube videos of bill
actually i see his own conference
talking it's like i don't know 10 years
ago and he goes on and he talks about um
what's the name of the it's like the
howard hughes company there's like it's
like a home builder uh tool like
powerbit or something
yeah i know you're talking about
no i think i think it's called the
howard use companies basically like
whatever that famous guy howard hughes
or whatever and he's got this company
they build homes and he'll give a talk
so what you do is you go give a talk
about like
a thesis that you are really bullish on
and basically like a big bet you're
making or you've already made basically
and you go pitch your case for that bet
and this kind of has like two fold
effects one if you're in the audience
you get ideas on investments um like you
know why this person's so bullish on
this thing it's it's interesting to hear
the case two it's only like the who's
who that talk like it's like the top top
guys um and that go and talk at this
thing and then the third thing is that
like you um for the speaker they get to
kind of like build their brand but they
also get to pump their bags so like
they've already made this bet then they
go talk here they get a bunch of
retention bunch of other people going to
invest in it and it might cause the
price to go up which is like a good
thing for them so they're helping
propagate the narrative that helps their
their case
so anyways you go hear him talk by the
end of the 40 minutes you're like
there's never been a better investment
on earth than the howard hughes company
right like you're like so convinced
because these guys are very convincing
and they have a great track record so
you're like wow whatever now if you
actually go look at the results it's
like i remember chamoth went and spoke
and he talked about how box like box.com
is like
like of all the tech companies we have
identified one winner that is going to
benefit the most from this cloud
movement and ai ml and its box and you
go look at the stock chart for box since
that day uh it's like down and to the
right you know what i mean it's like it
has not done well uh but they they put
together very convincing cases and of
course occasionally they're they're
correct so anyways at this year's zone
there was a really interesting talk
which was sam bankman freed talks to i
think patrick or john collison what the
patrick hollison's the
one of the brothers who started stripe
red head
or whatever
uh the redhead one i think they're are
they not popular
no patrick
they both actually did interviews
one interviewed stanley druckenmiller
awesome interview go watch it that was
the other brother the other one
interviewed sam
and first of all the one thing that
stood out is kind of like um
when you watch these guys do an
interview
it's basically like what if you had like
a world-class brain
become a podcaster for like you know
like like i'm talking world class like
these guys are some of the smartest
most well-read
best executors most like most
well-connected people on the planet or
they're the company they see everything
they were millionaires at like i don't
know seven they built cool [__] at 17
that like they sold for a million
dollars or whatever there's now they
built like 100 billion dollar company
and they're like the best of the best
like they're the best yc founders and yc
is the best group of founders right so
they're amazing and you hear them give
an interview they hear their talks and
how they frame questions that alone is
like worth the price of admission just
to see that
but then they ask questions and there so
he asked a question to sam bakeman free
he goes
i read something very interesting that
ftx as a you know 30 billion company
only has um
like 200 employees or something like
that and i believe you you know for the
first year the product was built by just
two engineers and even now you only have
sub 20 sub 30 engineers
a is that true
and b
what the hell is going on like do you is
ftx he's like either he's like i can
only think of one of two things either
ftx is simply like you have a unique set
of problems so you could do you can
operate your business differently or the
rest of us are doing this completely
wrong which is it
and um and he goes the latter
that's a really good way to frame a
question exactly
and so he goes uh he goes i i he laughs
he's like i think it's the latter and he
goes you know um we he's like
more i looked at tech companies i like
you know facebook google
successful tech companies
i i think i don't know for sure i can't
say like you know i don't know their
exact business but from what i can
gather
uh they
they employ an order of magnitude more
people than they need to you know and
he's like
how many he's like how many people do
you think
facebook would have optimally
uh and he's like you know he's like he's
like i don't know if let's say they have
50 000 employees
um you know that's somewhere between you
know like um
five to thirty times too many
and like
and so uh you know it's kind of shocking
to hear this and it's something i liked
it because i've believed this for a long
time which is that you um like most tech
companies are completely over hired i've
told this story before which is that
when i interviewed at twitch for our
acquisition uh they did the you know the
part of the interview is they at the end
of the interview they you know hey do
you have any questions for us and this
is my first one how many employees does
twitch have 1800 2000
how many do you think is the right
number for twitch like what do you think
is is
how many people do you guys actually
need to be like
firing on all cylinders
and like i would get basically three
reactions the first was sort of like
just like shock like what are you even
saying and are you insinuating that like
i shouldn't be here or like we shouldn't
hire you or that we hired too many
people we don't know what we're doing
like
you know the people were just like what
i don't get what you're getting at but
it's not good whatever you're getting
it's not no matter what interpretation i
have of this question it's pretty bad um
the second was
a genuine answer which was like you know
uh probably like you know
15 to 20 percent less but we you know
you don't know
you don't know over time who those top
performers are you figure that out and
like you know it's good to have buffer
and redundancy or whatever
and then uh i asked emmett the ceo and
he was like
i think 2500 and he's like you know
because his plan is like to hire and
grow and he's like
you know he he
and like we didn't get into a big debate
about it i was just curious what he
would say and so what was your reaction
to this thing where you found out that
ftx has like you know
20 engineers and is running this yeah
pretty
large tech platform and everybody else
has thousands of engineers
i think people over hire and so i wrote
um
a tweet that said you know i'm really
fascinated with the idea of just hiring
less people who are higher quality and
paying them a lot more versus hiring a
ton of people and most of them by
definition are pretty average
and you pay them a medium or market rate
i like that idea of doing the first
thing but is that actually practical and
what are some examples
and the reason why i wasn't sure if it
was actually practical is like even if
you get the highest performing people
in a room does it just become natural
still whereas like the 80 20 where 20 of
the people does 80 of the work and it's
just always and i think actually maybe
that will actually would still exist but
at like a higher caliber and then also i
was like i actually understand why you
want redundancies i understand why if
you rely on five people and three of
them quit like you're really screwed but
let me give you the and someone tweeted
out uh and i found two good examples one
example was sam bakeman free with ftx
and here's what he said here's the tweet
he actually tweeted this out i guess
after that talk kind of summarizing his
thoughts he goes i've looked into hyper
growth companies and time and time again
growing from 200 employees to 2 000
doesn't seem to 10x your product per
year productivity as a company in fact
sometimes it doesn't even one extra
productivity sometimes the more you hire
the less you get done so why exactly uh
is it that hiring doesn't scale the way
it should a coordination becomes really
hard and b diffusion of responsibility
five people could theoretically do
something maybe no one will actually
feel like they have to get it done and
have to do it and then uh he just goes
on to say that basically companies hire
more
uh sorry companies lower the bar as they
hire more and over time the average
co-worker people an actress becomes a
worse experience and incentives become
harder to align as people have less and
less of a sense of what each person is
doing
and i completely agree i think that them
i don't i'm not smart like these guys
where i can actually come up with a
number but i think a large percentage of
jobs at least in the tech world and i
would say most companies are [__]
jobs i'd call them [__] jobs and
they're only there because the person
who's running this particular division
has to request more budget and hire more
so they get more responsibility and more
credit and they seem more important so
then when they go to their next company
they get paid more and they can climb
the ladder because it seems like oh well
like you know you manage 200 people you
must be legit
yeah that's why i think it happens the
number of people under you is a is a
power consolidation technique inside of
large companies and even if people
aren't doing it for malicious reasons it
it is the incentive like you get it's
just the game a larger of a group of
people that you can manage and so your
incentive is to hire people promote them
to managers have them hire people have
them promote them to managers and have
like layers and layers of people
because if you were if you were
if everybody got the same budget and
then you were just measured on how much
you got done and you got to keep the
extra i think companies would work
wildly differently than they do today
right and he says something he goes in
that tweet he goes sam says he goes as
far as i can tell this is the most
common reason that successful companies
decay it's a race between how quickly
new employees can understand the culture
and how quickly people are hired the
faster you hire the harder it is to keep
everyone on the same page
and um
you know if you're growing at 50 a year
maybe you could still mentor each new
recruit and get them you know to learn
how you guys work but if you're going
300 a year each employee only has four
months to learn before they have to
start teaching
and meanwhile we you know you have to
also figure out how to make sure
compensation is fair coordination keeps
happening like i remember this inside of
uh
even a startup even a very small company
um when you go from one people to two
people
generally productivity increases like
almost every time
um one person to two people is almost
always a win
two people to three people
usually a win but there's usually a cost
which is oh now we have to have meetings
whereas before like one person the whole
project's in your head you don't have to
talk to anybody two people like
by default you're going to basically
share everything with the other
everybody because there's only one other
person
knows everything that's shared once you
have three people no longer does
everybody know everything that's going
on and basically i think there's this
rule which is that for every
um
[Music]
for every double of your employee base
you square the amount of communication
required meaning so if you go from four
to eight you don't that doesn't double
the communication it forexes the
communication or whatever right like uh
i don't do my public math there but it's
basically like a non-linear
like it's a non-nonlinear investment you
have to make in communication and
coordination and like suddenly it's like
oh man we have a 12 person team and like
it's really hard to keep everybody on
the same page and now i'm having to do
extra meetings that are all hands
meetings or things like that just to
keep 12 people organized now imagine
that at 1200 and imagine that of 12 000
miserable
it's miserable so the other example
by the way that someone i don't know if
anyone replied or how i found this but
have you heard of the company called
stream yard
stream yard now
they're in your world so go to stream i
think it's streamyard.com so they're in
like the streaming world are they like
canadians
uh maybe some easy way it's the easiest
way they say to create a professional
live stream so okay it gives you like a
it's like a broadcasting tool for live
streaming okay cool so this guy it was
two guys one guy named gage and i don't
remember the other guy amazing name gage
is the first day
yeah gage and dan yeah gage like rode a
dirt bike to school when he was a kid
and uh
yeah this guy's amazing so he um
so he started this company with dan and
they were basically i think just making
it away for like i think it was like
twitch folks you know or just like
streamers to stream but then eventually
they kind of pivoted a little bit so it
could be like a professional stream so
like i don't know who actually would do
a quote professional stream i guess like
a company but like it had all these like
d it had all these like obviously like
yeah so you just make it look cool and
really easy well anyway they launched
this in 19 or i think even 20 and it was
just them two and they got it to 3
million in arr just these two guys
then the pandemic hits and in one year
they go from 3 million to 30 million
annually recurring revenue wow zero
outside money just these two guys and
when they they eventually sold at the uh
so they launched i think in 19 the
pandemic hit went in 20 or 21
uh but basically in like one year they
went from 3 million to 30 million and
then they sold that same year to hop in
for 250 million dollars in cash
and these two guys owned the whole thing
and when they sold they basically scaled
the company
to 20 million in arr with five people
and by the time they sold they had 30
million and they had just hired the
seventh person
and this whole business was built with
just seven people really was built with
two or three people and then the second
half they were like our customer service
was just getting out of control and so
we had to have someone manage like an
agency who was doing our customer
service uh and and they're like it was
just like of course they did they kind
of were already killing it but they hit
a lick with like covid that like was
unexpected so that accelerated it but
they were doing three million with two
guys like a year and a half into the
business that's which is amazing for
software
um but it's a pretty ridiculous
it's a pretty ridiculous company you
should uh google like what the founders
look like i think they're like they look
like they're like 28 like they're like
kids
yeah i'm pretty sure i met these guys at
a conference by the way and now that now
that i'm seeing their faces um yeah gage
and dan but we're gonna call dan dirt so
this gage and dirt we're the co-founders
of stream yard
[Laughter]
um yeah i love it this is i mean that's
that's an amazing story of like you know
right place right time uh you know and
being ready to like surf a wave can i
tell you like another random business
like this that's like yeah just
deceptively big so my buddy corey um
tweeted this out he was like he's like
the uh the high school guy
no no this rory levy this is corey
nicholson um his thing is corey nceo is
his twitter account so uh corey's a good
dude he's a real young guy he's like
doing an e-commerce thing right now i
really like him like he's the one if we
were gonna do
southern sam's sticky icky this is the
guy that run it and he's down to run it
we're just waiting on you if you want to
run it but like he's a d2c guy who he's
really what he's really good at is he's
good at building a ddc product and using
tick tock to market it and um like
that's like his current like niche and
um
so anyways he goes
he goes next time you're stressing over
a business idea just remember there's a
website that just simply removes the
tick tock watermark from a video and
receives 37 million monthly visits and
has ads everywhere and so
it's called it's called sss tik i don't
know if you've ever seen this website
s-s-s-t-i-k so three s's and then tick
wow i'm looking at the traffic now
almost 40 million monthly visitors for
the last six months straight
and it's just plastered with that
i don't know i just like you know when
you if you cr tick tock is a great way
to create videos but it always keeps the
tick tock watermark in there
and so i guess this is a way to remove
the watermark
because i'm pretty sure if you post a
watermarked video from tiktok onto
twitter i always feel like they like
have a way to like downvote it you know
what i mean so it doesn't get shown yeah
is that legitimate
i i don't know if it i don't know if
it's that i
i
really don't give twitter that much
credit like yeah i don't think they can
build a feature that smart but um but i
know for facebook i think facebook if
you upload a
watermark video as an ad because those
tick top videos do great as ads um they
won't let you run it because it's got a
tick tock thing you're basically
promoting their competitor right so you
have to like get the raw video
dude this is crazy i'm looking at the
traffic now and so it gets like 40
million a month it looks like around
that and they're from every country so
united states only makes up uh eight
percent of the traffic and then there's
like colombia philippines mexico peru
peru's the biggest source
which is makes up ten percent this is
crazy what a crazy business do you think
this makes money surely it makes some
but
you think this is big
yeah i think it is by the way okay so i
tried to get in touch with this so i
don't have the full story on this but um
go to you're gonna love this this is
like i might be telling you about
something like you already know you're
gonna be like
my cousin started this go to
eggcartons.com
all right
why would my i don't have
a cousin would start a cartons.com what
is this egg
i don't know this this is just a sandbar
special right here it's just like
did you know there's a business called
egg cart
so many people think that i'm like
i thought you were safe i'm from the
midwest so many people think they're
like oh like hey i want to go hunting
can you like teach me how to hunt like
they think that i'm like from like a
rural southern area i'm not i don't know
anything about that like i i i'm like
when you think of
they they hear i'm from st louis
missouri and they think it's the country
i'm like think of detroit that's kind of
like where i was raised like that's it's
more like detroit than it is are you
more like the rural area
are you more likely to go
bow hunting or get a pedicure
dude
well neither
people from missouri don't get pedicures
at least men don't but bow hunting like
i only know about bow hunting from like
the tv show napoleon dynamite where they
talk about like a bow staff like i don't
even know like i don't know what bo i've
never killed a animal before
no i've never done any of that you don't
have the you don't have the urge to
i definitely do it would be fun to look
something in the eye and then consume it
i think that would be exciting but
anyway
okay so back to eggcards.com all right
so
basically it's just a website that sells
like the actual packaging you need for
eggs so every form factor of eggs you
got the 12 one you got the 24 pack you
got the plastic one you got the foam one
you got the good for the environment one
and
i thought this was really interesting
because this is this is a multi-million
dollar business that just is like
wholesale selling packaging for eggs
and they just like if you go to the
website it's like egg cartons.com call
1-888-852-5340 right and it's like you
know when that's in your logo that this
business prints cash because it's like
oh yeah we got like just this like you
know every grocery store in america
every corner store in america they just
eggcartons.com and they they got my
number you know in their phone book
and uh it's like the biggest tell and so
what was interesting about this is i was
like who owns this thing
and then if you look up egg cards.com
owner
you're gonna see um this woman named
sarah moore
and sarah moore if you go look at her
thing it says her linkedin says sarah
egg carton and packaging fanatic
and she's been doing this for four years
and before that she went to harvard
business school
and so i was like who is this and
basically this is somebody who's like an
m as a mba private equity type
that identified this business that's
been around for 20 years
and um basically you know like when you
know either bought it took it over
um
or you know did something i don't think
it's like her dad is the owner because
there's this other guy paul
b something who you know was the owner
of it for 19 years now he says he's
semi-retired but i think she bought it
and um i was like wow this is a
this is a like fascinating like path to
pick uh for somebody who's just like
smart and is like you know what i'm
gonna go fish where nobody else is
fishing instead of going to try to build
the next social app or the next crypto
thing or the next podcast it's like let
me go identify one of these businesses
that's like a wholesaler of packaging by
the company and then just like you know
modernize it and grow it
so
is this sarah moore from
uh massachusetts
oh wow are you sure this woman owns
so this woman does not look at all like
you're going to think of a
a carton sales person
this is the owner are you like if you
look if you look at her picture what
look at her picture what's your guess
what does this woman do
like enterprise sales at salesforce
exactly i was gonna say the exact same
thing she sells high-end enterprise
software
or she runs an ad agency
or you know like whatever i don't know
she's a like uh you know
professor and part-time model or
something like that right it's like
she's crazy she's like a really
good-looking harvard person and i would
not expect her to
do any of this in sutton massachusetts
like this is crazy if you look at the
guy who's the previous owner you go to
his uh linkedin it's like a dude on the
like he's got his neck sideways he's on
the phone he's like a guy's computer
he's like looking up someone took this
photo of him and that's the best photo
he has of himself
yeah
his desk has like you know
1970s world series like you know
ball from the game he was out yeah and
he's got like a marble red in his mouth
that's exactly how i would imagine this
this is crazy how'd you find this
so because i just saw the tweet about
the about the egg carton i went down the
rabbit hole i found a pdf
and it says uh she purchased it in 2017
after her after getting her mba from
harvard and um you know now she has a
private equity she's that she did that
by the way in her 20s
so she's got a private equity company
that basically does egg cards.com fall
harvest products and those both those
both serve the egg producing company uh
sorry industry
and um and king supply which provides
plumbing materials to campgrounds and
parks
and i was like what the hell like who is
this person what are they doing and so i
by the way i might have some of these
wrong because i tried to get in touch
with her i emailed her and i just
subject line like holy [__] you know
first line egg cartons you know like who
would have thought this is amazing and i
sent her i was like look
um
you know i want to know more about you
but i don't want to schedule time and i
for you or for me like here's a google
doc like would you mind just answering
these questions and so i'm waiting on
her to answer these questions now
because i have i must know more i must
know where so this is her family
business like how did she get into this
so this like model-looking harvard grad
owns an a-cart business she owns a
plumbing supplies business is that right
and i don't know what a fall harvest
what is fall harvest products what do
you make when you sell that i think it's
also it's also for the egg industry
what
this is awesome this is a really good
find i love sarah moore sarah moore
i love women named sarah my wife's name
is sarah i love sarah moore he's great
it's not where i thought you would go
with that one
i love a woman named sarah
no this woman's awesome i'm a big
[__] factor you're right
party
[Laughter]
my wife's name's sarah and there's this
woman i admire who like with the harvard
and knows it eighth guard business who's
also named sarah she's i'm fond of hers
founder of uh
founder of spanx pants love when pants
make you look dinner sarah blakely
another great sarah yeah i'm a big fan
of this this is a good find why did the
person tweet about it
uh i don't even know it was like uh what
did they say they go
i think so the thread was like a kind of
a golden thread where it was like boring
businesses are the best businesses and
um
and then somebody uh patrick patrick b
johnson said i got one that's even
better edcards.com this is a
multi-million dollar business
and that was the only reply to the
threat by the way this wasn't like a
popular threat some one guy tweeted that
first tweet this guy you dm that guy
he knows something it's like a
heat-seeking missile yeah he knows
something no i didn't reach out to this
guy uh he's got like a picture that
makes it look a little crazy um and so i
was like i don't know
i mean
like assault you it's on twitter
so like okay let me read you his bio
this is why i was like uh
i want to have a conversation right now
beats up indian guys
you know here it goes teen vogue is this
isn't bile ting teen vogue called me a
visionary elite daily called me a genius
link in bio then he goes at ramit
blocked me is my biggest accomplishment
i'm the founder of progress labs
okay yeah i wouldn't want to talk to
that guy either
either he's awesome or he's completely
not awesome and i just didn't have the
energy to go find out
this is a badass fine i'm all about is
it egg cartons a cartons.com i'm all
about this because if anyone wants to
give my birthday gift for you
if anyone can find sarah moore so please
find sarah moore
and uh
and tell her to tell her to uh join the
pod there's this one woman i don't know
if i told you this did you see the tweet
where i saw this lady at uh whole foods
and i thought it was cool and i just
tweeted out a picture
no wait what happened
so there was this lady giving out
samples at whole foods
and
the sample was called uh i actually
don't know what it was jesha j
e s h a
and uh she it's like a sourdough do you
know anything about sourdough bread like
i don't know like entirely behind it but
it like something involving like it
doesn't have yeast or something like
something where like it you you actually
digest it a little bit easier and it
doesn't make you as bloated at least
when i eat it because it doesn't have
like yeast it like is missing it's a
there's one ingredient that's missing
that just makes it feel sometimes feel
better on your stomach so she made
sourdough like mix that you can use for
like pancakes and like muffins and [__]
like that and i was just talking and i
just like went to the whole foods and i
saw her i was like oh let me try some of
this i was like this is great is this
your business she's like yeah i just
started it like six months ago and i
just cold emailed someone
at whole foods asking if we could sell
in the store and they said yeah and now
they're stacking it on all the shelves i
was like oh wow that's a pretty good
story uh you know what's your background
she's like oh i just worked at a fintech
startup for a bunch of years and i just
always wanted to do this and i just
saved up a little bit of money and i
quit and i just launched it and i cold
emailed them and i just kind of figured
it out
and i just tweeted that one tweet it was
it was a picture of her and it was like
you know worked on fintech quit uh
started this in six months got the whole
food just cold emailed someone
and uh it got read by like two million
people that tweet and she like me and i
have no idea who she was i didn't even
like know her handle and she like
somehow i i at the end of the tweet i
was like if you know who she is send
this to her and you know she'll like
know where all the sales came from
apparently she like knocked it out the
park with sales um all from just this
one little tweet and then i did the same
thing with a pool company trek pools and
they sold a [__] ton of pools i like
from from this mention it's kind of
funny just uh these silly little tweets
actually move the needle for people
so you're saying
if you're out there and you'd like your
needle moved
your boys are available for hiring
bribes actually not even for hire just
bribes
yeah just money
send us
awesome stuff
or cash in some kind of briefcase
and we will move the needle for you
needle movers
yeah one eight hundred
five five hundred move my needle
[Laughter]
all right that's the episode i think hey
we're just a couple of needle movers
cultivating that multi-trillionaire
mindset hashtag grindset
[Music]
you